et on reste aux états unis avec la
california un des états les plus touchés
par le cos vide 19 pour endiguer
l'épidémie certaines villes comme san
francisco on met à disposition des
logements d'urgence pour les sans abri
conséquence les autorités doit faire
face à un arrivage massif
les précisions de david kelly à chaque
coin de rue ou presque il est même image
san francisco doit faire face à un
afflux inédit de sans abri et anciens
détenus libérés pour cause de kobe 19 la
raison les mesures ambitieuses prises
par la ville louée des milliers de
chambres d'hôtel vacante pour fournir un
logement d'urgence aux sans abri pendant
l'épidémie
les services des deux sont donc débordés
et ne peuvent répondre à une demande
constante venant bien souvent d'autres
régions des états unis ils viennent ici
parce qu'ils croient qu'ils peuvent
obtenir une teinte et qu'ils peuvent
entrer dans le système pour obtenir un
logement et c'est donc vraiment un
fardeau pour notre système qui est déjà
imposants conséquence de cet afflux
les organismes de bienfaisance
alimentaires ont vu leurs distributions
de repas augmenter drastiquement
une situation qui ne s'améliore pas
malgré le déconfinement de la californie
prévu ce vendredi syntonisent existe
depuis soixante dix ans et nous
assistons certainement un afflux de
personnes inédit utilisant nos services
avant le couvent et 19 il y avait en
moyenne environ 2300 personnes par jour
et maintenant nous envoyer aux moyennes
3300 voire trois mille huit cents par
jour
les autorités n'avaient pas prévu un tel
arrivage de personnes dans le besoin
la californie étant l'un des états les
plus touchés par la pandémie avec plus
de 58 mille cas confirmés et près de
2000 380 décès liés à la maladie